foreign
since the world became dependent on oil
and gas we've been through cycle after
cycle of boom and bust of Crisis and
Recovery in the 1970s the 90s and now in
2022 with Russia's war against Ukraine
we find ourselves once again in the grip
of soaring fossil fuel prices that have
exposed so many countries to deep social
and economic strife
instead of the usual cycle of Crisis and
then return to a fragile status quo this
can and must be the last time that we
are left so vulnerable
let me tell you why
in the last year we've reached
unprecedented clarity about the fact
that there is no room for new fossil
fuel infrastructure if we are to have a
decent shot of limiting the warming of
our climate to 1.5 degrees
These Warnings have sounded against a
terrifying backdrop of climate chaos
Europe's river is running dry
apocalyptic flooding in Pakistan
Savage wildfires heat and drought across
the world
the devastation wrought by our warming
climate driven by the burning of oil gas
and coal can no longer be ignored
at the same time
a new reality also driven by our
dependency on fossil fuels has been
playing out in some of the richest
countries in the world
in the UK millions of people
are coming face to face with the
desperate reality behind the term fuel
poverty
we've had stories about pensioners
riding public buses all day to stay warm
of local councils opening warm banks for
people who can't afford to heat their
homes
before the UK government announced that
it was going to freeze the unit price of
energy in what is considered to be the
single most expensive policy
announcement since the second world war
40 percent of people living in the UK
were expected to be in fuel poverty by
the end of this year
even with that price freeze 6.7 million
households will struggle to pay their
energy bills
how did we get here
why is the situation so acute
the answer
is gas
the UK is exceptionally reliant on gas
the vast majority of our homes are gas
heated and a big chunk of our
electricity is generated by gas-fired
power stations with that comes extreme
vulnerability to International grass gas
prices that are now projected to stay
unusually high until at least 2025.
in the UK and indeed across Europe This
is a moment of huge peril
and of huge opportunity
as a climate change lawyer and
campaigner working in the UK and across
the global North conversations around
fossil fuels in the recent past
including about our domestic significant
oil and gas industry here in the UK
those conversations have until recently
been about the impact of climate change
that are wreaking havoc in other parts
of the world or about impacts that are
portrayed as fleeting in the UK
it's been very easy for politicians in a
media focused on short-term short-term
news Cycles to dismiss but that has now
changed forever
the only way to address our energy
affordability crisis is to address its
root cause and that is our dependency on
fossil fuels that's now common cause not
just across the climate movement but
across sectors working on inequality and
poverty as well
renewable energy sources which are are
only passed away from climate
catastrophe sources like solar and wind
those are now nine times cheaper than
gas as a source of electricity in the UK
moreover we know that we can
significantly reduce our energy demand
here by upgrading our homes which are
among the coldest and leakiest in Europe
while politicians and the fossil fuel
Industries proxies might in this moment
and indeed are in this moment trying to
double down on fossil fuel production as
a solution to our Sky High Energy bills
they are about to find out in short
order that in a moment of acute crisis
like this when millions of people are
experiencing the impacts in such a
material and tangible way there is no
room for peddling false hope there is
nowhere to hide and while oil and gas
companies continue to record record
profits off the same forces that are
driving families all over the UK into
despair it will become even more clear
incontrovertibly clear that boom times
for the oil and gas industry are bad
times for the rest of us
across the UK there are new movements
emerging to make sure that we are never
put in this position again
from campaigns like warm this winter to
enough is enough
to movements to stop the opening up of
new oil and gas Fields like stop
rosebank to litigation and targeted
advocacy there is a wave of action
coming to make sure that this is the
last cycle this is the last time this
can and must be the last alarm Bell to
sound about the true cost of our
Reliance on fossil fuels before we step
into a more safe more just future for us
all thank you
[Applause]